hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com today we're going to
be looking at the steinis lewis trap it
derives from the bishop's opening which
is e4
e5 and bishop to c4 now black may
respond with bishop c5 and now we're
going to play pawn b4 this is my typical
response if they play bishop c5 has it
feels similar to the evans gambit where
you give up this pawn on b4 after they
capture you can play c3 forcing their
bishop to come back and then play d4
really controlling the center of the
board anytime you give up material you
want to have some compensation so
controlling the center of the board
is the way i like to go about it but
after they take on b4 you have another
option and that is to start to go down
this path of the lewis trap
and it starts with the idea of
really controlling this f file similar
to in the king's gambit and that's with
pawn to f4 this is when i first came
across this what intrigued me because
already this is how i like to play in
the bishop's opening if they play bishop
c5
and the king's game it is my favorite
opening of all time just very familiar
with my bishop on c4 attacking this weak
square on f7 and then just lining up all
my material on this f file and really
putting a lot of pressure on my
opponent's king
now they could take on f4 but they could
also play knight c6 many times when
you're putting something strange on your
opponent they may just develop more
material and say hey i know i need to
get more material involved into the game
so i'm just going to play it safe played
knight c6 which i think is the most
common line
defending the square on e5
we are now going to continue to get more
material involved into the game with
knight f3 this does a few things one
adds another attacker on the e5 square
it also prepares for our knight to come
to g5 which now the knight and the
bishop are both eyeing down this f7
square which is very weak for black
early on only the king is protecting it
and it also opens up more importantly
for our king to castle on the king side
anytime you play f4 in the king's gambit
or in this particular line you usually
want to be castling king side to get
your rook on the f file to attack this
f7 square and that's exactly what we're
going to be doing
here
now black has a few options and we'll
look at you know if they play the pawn
takes on f4
okay well now we can play go back to i
would say plan b
playing a's if they just continue with
what we're hoping for in this trap but
now okay they play their bishop back and
now we control the center of the board
with d4 we can cast on the king's side
still have a lot of the same
ideas in our mind that's completely fine
we're going to get this pawn back on f4
pretty easily with our bishop here
and now we control the center of the
board and this f file is still for
us to attack but if they say you know
what
we're not going to take instead we're
going to play d6 again getting more
mature involved into the game if you
play against the king's gambit
a lot you'll know that this d6 move is
very very common it opens up for the
light square bishop to get involved into
the game so i think you'll see this
more times than not
we are going to continue with our game
plan and that's castle on the king side
now from here one option that black has
is to play bishop g4 if they don't i
still like our setup this is exactly
what we're going for and we have a lot
of threats already but if they play
bishop g4 this is the trap that we have
laid for them because we can immediately
take on f7 and this just shows you
how much of a threat that we have when
our bishop's on c4 and our opponent has
their pawn on e5 and e6 opening up for
these light squares for us to take here
on f7 because if they take
well now you can start to see we have
knight g5 this opens up this is a check
on the king on f7 but it also opens up
for a queen to take on
g4 now the worst option they could do
from here
is to go and take with their queen and
say
okay yeah uh you
we're just gonna take your knight if you
take our bishop we're protecting that
that's fine but you can see because the
rook is on f1 we have the discovered
check with pawn takes here check and now
they're going to be forced to move their
king and we can just gobble up their
bishop on g4
don't think they're going to play the
worst move but just give you an idea of
the threats that we have
but even still okay now we know
that they're not going to take with
their queen maybe they move their king
they come back to king to e8
okay well now we can just take the
bishop on g4 and you can see their king
is going to be in a lot of danger can't
castle on either side of the board it's
going to be in the center and now we
have a lot of threats
now if we come back you can see that e8
is important because let's say they just
come back to f8 i think this is a much
worse move because now we play queen
takes on g4
and the threat here is knight to e6 you
can see this is forking the queen and
the king so that's gonna be a tough spot
so now they come to e8 but now we can
just play
knight to e6 this was still the threat
even in the other move when they had
king on e8 initially we just bring our
knight to e6 attacking the queen
once the queen moves it doesn't matter
even if it comes to e7 protecting the g7
square we can still play knight takes g7
attacking the king here and just picking
up an extra pawn remember we still have
this rook on f1
this bishop on b4 when it came over here
took that pawn it's really not doing
anything in the game at all
our king is pretty safe over here on g1
if the bishop ever came to c5 we could
just move it away so that's not really a
threat that we have to worry about
and we can just continue to add more
pressure on our opponent
now that was looking if they captured
our bishop on f7 let's look back and see
what happens if they don't take our
bishop on f7 okay well really i think
the only option would be
king f8 yes they could block their queen
if they wanted to with
king to e7 i think that's probably
getting a little too cute but
king to f8 makes some sense yes it is on
the f-file but there's a lot of pieces
that would have to be removed before
this rook could really threaten the king
here on f8
but from now
it's still attacking our bishop on f7 so
we can just bring our bishop back to b3
this is a pretty common square that
bobby fischer used to play the bishop on
b3 with this long light square diagonal
still open
always has to be worried about this
threat black does of the bishop just
attacking some of the critical squares
that black has access to
they could play bishop c5 attacking our
king at any point but we could just play
king h1 doesn't really matter too much
and now if they want to capture
the pawn on f4
then we can just play bishop b2 as soon
as they play the pawn away from e5 we
can just strike with bishop b2 and now
we have both of our bishops eyeing down
on the king's side they don't have
king side safety and so their king is
completely exposed we can get our queen
involved into the game we still have a
rook on the f5 i think this is very very
good for us if they don't take the pawn
maybe instead they played knight f6
well now we can just take that pawn
if they take the pawn well now we play
pawn to d3 solidify this pawn chain our
king is safe on h1 we can get our dark
square bishop involved into the game we
can always bring it to b2 as well
we can start to get our knight involved
into the game we still have this rook on
this open file with both of these
knights only blocking the king here on
f8 so i think all in all really depends
on how black moves but we have a lot of
threats
doesn't matter where they end up so this
is another one of those openings that i
really like because it follows a lot of
the same principles that i like to play
in chess already
and it just allows my opponents to make
a lot of mistakes so remember to come in
here we are going to castle and then
just see what our opponent's doing if
they try to come down and pin down our
knight to the queen we say not not so
fast my friend we're just going to go
and take up here on f7 so that is the
steines lowest trap hopefully enjoyed
this video
if you wouldn't mind hitting that like
button let me know in the comment
section below below that you enjoyed it
but thanks so much for watching i'll see
you in the next video
you